the Joe Rogan experience now when you
went to jail you had a sudden you your
your case was horrible I mean it was it
was so depressing
to hear that you were going to jail for
making bongs yeah I mean it just the
whole thing was so sick and that they
were threatening to put your family in
jail and that's how they sent you to
jail
you couldn't smoke pot for a while after
that right years how long probably three
years you're on probation probation pre
probation before you went to jail pre
pre trial because if you get caught in
you end up getting tortured what the
whole time I was there nine months I was
there I couldn't smoke they tested me
all the time they try to catch me mm-hmm
there's nothing to catch and then a year
after that I was on probation and I
never smoked I can quit you know I got
willpower you know I can quit I quit
smoking I quit drinking I quit eating
bad food whatever but you had the record
well for one thing that happened that
was great who was that you became even
more of a hero to the cannabis community
because people knew you truly were a
martyr and it was outrageous and it was
so it was so wrong that even people that
didn't smoke pot really tell the [ __ ]
you arrested Tommy Chong they come on
like all the terrorists in the world the
criminals are rapists and murderers I
know you gonna put Tommy John and Joe
yeah like what are we protecting or
serving what are we doing here which one
which one is that yeah they were just
showing off showing off but once I once
I get in I was in there with a lot of
people that were unjustly incarcerated I
was in there with the orthopedic surgeon
for the Rams and he he had been in
attacks it wasn't it was legal at the
time he did it which was that he had a
big cart collection and he and he rode
off the car collection somehow and then
the IRS changed people and and next
thing you know they they came to him and
said you owe all this money and if you
don't pay it you got to go to jail and
he couldn't pay it so he went to jail oh
this is the earth of Pedic surgeon he's
like super straight the street is one of
the straightest guys ever met
and there was another guy that figured
out the OJ tax scheme you know how OJ
can keep his money from the pension
defenses in Florida yeah well it's a
it's a law that a loophole that allowed
you know OJT heba's taxes
I mean tax free money and so so this
accountant figured out how to do it and
he started getting rich people so they
didn't have to pay taxes and so rather
than to change the law or do anything
like that they just put his ass in jail
because they could and they put him in
there for a year and he wasn't doing
anything illegal
nothing illegal except and then they
told him or you you're going to get out
in a year but you're not going to do
that tax thing anymore Wow yeah no no
the government the IRS is Cree do not
want to owe them money
[Applause]